festation toujours à paris cette fois ci
pour la sauvegarde des terres agricoles
quelques centaines de personnes sont
réunies place de la république pour
lutter contre le projet de bétonisation
du triangle de gonesse sur ses terres
agricoles d'île de france jean castex a
lancé la construction d'une gare et
d'une école internationale
les activistes écologistes dénoncent à
mon sens quand on voit quelle loi climat
qui a été votée qu'il y a juste d'être
voté et qui quand même disait on va
freiner ou stopper l'artificialisation
des terres
on voit que le gouvernement fait
exactement le contraire puisque quelques
jours après castex vient annoncer et
bien on va bétonner une partie de la
connaissent 30 messe après l'abandon de
ropa situe quand on s'est félicité il
avait l'occasion de donner un signal
vers l'avenir pour faire face au
réchauffement climatique de donner envie
à développer des projets de transition
écologique de faire évoluer la culture
villes de france le gouvernement a
enfanté une occasion mme est en train de
rater une belle occasion qu'il avait sur
le triangle de gonesse développer un
projet agricole de dimension régionale
un projet de transition écologique avec
eux avec le pro